نفت الخارجيه الامريكيه تصريحات مسؤولين
ايرانيين بشان التوصل لاتفاق تبادل
السجناء وصفه اياها بالكذبه الاخرى التي
تزيد في معاناه عائلاتهم في المقابل
استغربت الخارجيه الايرانيه الموقف
الامريكي قائله ان لدى واشنطن سجلا سيئا
من عدم الالتزام بالاتفاقيه السابقه سواء
تعلق الامر بتبادل الاسراء او الملف
النووي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
حيثيات وظروف صفقه تبادل الاسرى بين
الولايات المتحده وايران والتي نفتها
الاداره الامريكيه بينما تصف طهران واشنطن
بانها صاحبه سجل سيء في الالتزام
بالاتفاقيات والتفاهمات السابقه
وكيف ستنعكس هذه الظروف على مسار العلاقات
الايرانيه الغربيه في خضم نشاط سياسي
تشهده منطقه الشرق الاوسط وزياد سرعه
وتيره التقارب الايراني مع روسيا والصين
في عده مجالات
وما هي افاق الوصول الى تفاهمات ايرانيه
امام امريكيه وما مدى تاثيرها على دول
المنطقه وعلى مسار التوتر بين الغربي
وروسيا
[موسيقى]
جددت المواقف الايرانيه والامريكيه من ملف
تبادل السجناء تسليط الضوء على استحكام
ازمه الثقه بين طهران وواشنطن وغيرها من
العواصم الغربيه
ازمه تلقي بظلالها على عدد من الملفات
العالقه التي تتعثر الى حد الان جهود
تسويتها كما هو الحال في الملف النووي
الايراني
التوقعات باختراق باختراق ما فيما يتعلق
بملف السجناء كانت قد انتعشت على وقع
تقرير
للفاينز نقلت فيه عن دبلوماسيا غربي رفيع
في طهران ان هناك الزخاما جديدا لامكانيه
تبادل اسرى بين الولايات المتحده وايران
واضافت الصحيفه عما وصفته بالمصدر المطلع
ان المناقشات لا تزال جاريه بشان الافراج
عن الاموال الايرانيه وكان المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه قد اشار الى ان واشنطن
تعمل بلا كلل من اجل تامين اطلاق سراح
الامريكيين ثلاث المحتجزين في ايران الا
ان الاداره الامريكيه لم تؤكد قول وزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير عبد اللهيان
ان ايران توصلت مؤخرا لاتفاق لتبادل
السجناء مع الولايات المتحده عبد الله
اضاف ان طهران تواصل تبادل الرسائل مع
واشنطن بشان اعاده تفعيل الاتفاق النووي
قائلا ان اداره بايدن لا تتحلى بالشجاعه
والجراه الكافيهتين لاتخاذ قرار بهذا
الشان وتشير تقارير الى ان الولايات
المتحده لا تنظر بعين الارتياح للتقارب
المتزايد بين ايران وكل من الصين وروسيا
على اكثر من صعيد وهو ما تجلى في مناسبات
عده من بينها الترحيب والحذر بالاتفاق
السعودي الايراني الذي رعته الصين
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من طهران
الدكتور عماد ابو شناس رئيس نقابه مراكز
الابحاث والدراسات في ايران ومن واشنطن
الدكتور اليكس فاتنكا مدير برنامج ايران
في معهد الشرق الاوسط
وابدا معك دكتور عماد ارشناس من طهران
الوزير وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان قال انه جرى التواصل الى اتفاق
في الايام الماضيه بشان
تبازل السجناء مع الولايات المتحده لكن
فيما بعد بعد النفي الامريكي الخارجيه
الايرانيه تحدثت عن اتفاق عام 2022 يعني
العام الماضي
كيف حصل هذا اللغط ما بين الايام الماضيه
وقبل سنه من اليوم
تحياتي لك يا استاذ حسن للسيد علي
الاعزاء لا الامر ليس باللغت عمليا كان
هناك اتفاقا في شهر شباط عام 2022 بين
ايران والولايات المتحده في جنيف انا
اعطيك حتى المعلومات بدقه لحتى يعني
يحلل لغه اذا ما اردنا ان نقول في حين
كانت هناك مفاوضات في فيينا كانت هناك
مفاوضات امنيه اخرى تجرى في جناب وفي عمان
وتم الاتفاق على الافراج عن السجناء بين
اجانبين اضافه الى الافراج عن
الارصده الايرانيه المجمده في كوريا
الجنوبيه وقسم من الارصده المجمده في
العراق وبعض الارصده الاخرى وعمليا حتى
قام الامريكان بالنقل قسم من الارصده الى
عمان وتم الافراج عن صيامك نماذج حينها
وبعدها
الامريكيين تراجعوا في اخر لحظه لانهم
راوا ان ان الامر امر سري او اعتبروا ان
الاتفاق سري ولكن هنا في ايران تم تسريب
موضوع الاتفاق الى وسائل الاعلام
والامريكان قالوا ان الموضوع ممكن ان يؤثر
على الانتخابات لهذا تراجعوا عن هذا في
العام 22 هذا في العام 22 نعم نعم
منذ حوالي الاسبوعين ارسلوا رساله الى
[موسيقى]
الايرانيين عبر وزير الخارجيه العراقيه
تسلمها السيد حسين امير عبد الله هيان
بعدها كذب الامريكيون ولكن عمليا ارسلوا
الرساله واساس الرساله كان هناك عده بنود
احد البنود يعني للعوده الى الاتفاق
النووي والتعامل بين اجانبين وغيرها لربما
خارج اطار هذا الحلقه ان اتكلم عن البنود
ولكن احد البنود كان الافراج عن السجناء
وتوجه السيد
باقراني الى عمان
لاعاده الاتفاق على الافراج عن السجناء
وكان باقي ريكان عده ايام في عمان وتم
الاتفاق على الافراج عن السجناء والارصده
الايرانيه وبعد ان اعلن السيد امير عبد
الهيان عن التوصل على عن هذا الاتفاق
تراجع الامريكيون مره اخرى
في هذه النقطه
لنستوضح فقط رساله اتت رساله امريكيه الى
وزير الخارجيه نقلها وزير الخارجيه
العراقي توجه محمد باقر كني الى
عمان طبعا بناء على هذه الرساله توجهها
الى عمان تقول جرى الاتفاق على تبادل
السجناء هناك مع من جرى الاتفاق هل كان
هناك موفد امريكي موجود في عمان
نعم يبدو انه كان هناك واسطه امريكيه
واسطه عبر الواسطه تحدثوا مع بعض وتم
الاتفاق على تنفيذ الاتفاق المبرره عام
يعني منذ عام يعني تم الاتفاق على اعاده
تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق الذي حصل منذ عام طيب
ايضا قبل ان ننتقل الى ضيفنا الامريكي
لنفذ للظروف اكثر طيب انت تحدثت عن ان
اتفاق عام 22 كان سله متكامله ما الذي
تغير حتى يرسل الامريكيون رساله الى
الايرانيين تتعلق فقط
بمساله تبادل السجناء مع العلم انها سله
متكامله كما فهمت منك
باختصار
نعم هم اوقفوا تنفيذ الاتفاق الاتفاق حصل
تم التوقيع عليه كان اتفاقا حتى مكتوبا
يعني لم يكن الاتفاق اتفاقا شفهيا كان
اتفاقا مكتوبا حصل في جنيف وبدات تنفيذه
واوقفوا تنفيذه اليوم عادوا ويقولون نريد
تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق الذي حصل فيه جنيف منذ
عام
ضيفنا من واشنطن اذا هذه الروايه
الايرانيه لموضوع الاتفاق بحسب الروايه
الايرانيه الولايات المتحده اخلت بهذا
الاتفاق ليس الاتفاق الاول الذي تقل به
الولايات المتحده
ولها سجل سيء في هذا المجال هكذا تصف
ايران وضع الولايات المتحده مع الاتفاقيات
التي تبرم مع طهران
اول شيء اقوله انه عندما يدخل لديك علاقات
سيئه وعذائيه بين بلدين كما هو الحال بين
ايران ولايات المتحده لمده 44 سنه فسنتحكم
دائما حالات شك
والشعور بالخيانه من جانب الاخر حول مجره
التفاوض عليه والامه كذلك اليوم فاعتماد
على من تطرح السؤال في واشنطن او طهران
ستسمع ان الطرف الاخر هو الذي لم يتعرك
بحسن النوايا لا اعرف بالضبط
ما هي النسخه الايرانيه حول ما جرى سمعنا
بعضها طبعا ولكن لما اعلمه حقا هو انه في
واش هناك امر واحد واضح تماما ونداله
بايدن تريد من حيث المبدا اطلاق السراح
المواطنين الامريكيين ثلاثه
واسمائهم يذكرها عودتهم الى الولايات
المتحده
واستعداد للتفاوض حول عليك ولكن من الواضح
ان المفاوضات لم تكن مثمره لحد الان لكن
اودنا نوضح نقطه اخيره سبب اجراعنا هذا
النقاش اصلا حول من قال ماذا ومتى ولماذا
فما الى ذلك هو بشكل كبير وبشكل كبير جدا
هو نتيجه حقيقه ان طهران ترفض التفاوض مع
الامريكان بشكل مباشر لهذا السبب لدينا
دول مختلفه عمان العراق وغيرها يشاركون في
العمل اذ لو كانت ايران فعلا تريد ان
تتقدم في هذا المسار الدبلوماسي فانا
الاوان لها ان تفكر بالاتصال والمتفاوض
المباشر مع المسؤولين الامريكان في
المنطقه والذين هم مستعدون للكلام معهم
طيب لماذا
برايك لماذا وزير الخارجيه الايراني
يعلن عن اتفاق اذا لم يكن موجودا بالفعل
يعني اين مصلحه ايران في ان تعلن عن
الاتفاق مع الولايات المتحده على تبادل
سجناء اذا لم يكن هذا الاتفاق قد حصل فعلا
اقول لكم فقط انه ليس ليس لا احكي لك ليس
النسخه الامريكيه حول التقييم لماذا قال
ذلك عبد الله بلاهيان اعطيكم النسخه
الايرانيه التي قراتها منشوره في الوسائل
الاعلام الايرانيه في طرمان هؤلاء
المحللون الايرانيون يقولون امير عبدالله
حيان يفتح
وتشير الى انتخابات مفاوضات المزعومه
لاعطاء الاتباع بان ايران قادره على
التجاوز الضغوط للتعرض لها فمثلا العمله
الايرانيه الريال تحت ضغوط شديده
وما ان تكون هناك اي افاق
للتفاوض مع الامريكان
تعزز ويقول الاسواق ترحب بهذا وبالتالي
فانه وزير خارج الايراني يحاول ان يقوم
بمساعده الاقتصاد الايراني بطرحه موضوع ان
هناك محادثات تجري ولايه المتحده حتى انهم
تحصل على مستوى المهم او مؤثر دكتور عماد
لماذا يعلن الوزير عبد الله هيان هذا
الامر اذا لم يكن هناك تاكيد يعني لم يكن
هناك
ما يثبت ان الولايات المتحده
فعلا
قبلت وهي في طريقها للتنفيذ لماذا يظهر
بهذا المظهر هل المساله كما يقول ضيفنا من
واشنطن محاوله اراحه الاسواق الماليه
وتسويق الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه داخل ايران
لاسباب داخليه
لا ابدا هذا غير صحيح يعني هناك البعض في
الداخل الايراني والبعض الموجودون في خارج
ايران
المعارضين يعني عمليا للحكومه او النظام
الايراني هم يريدون تخريب السيد امير عبد
الله هيا امير عبد الله شخصيته ليست كذلك
يعني هو لا يخرج بتصريح الا اذا ما كان
متاكدا من ان هناك شيء موجود يعني انا
اعرف السيد امير عبد الله منذ اكثر من 30
عاما وهو شخصيته ليست كذلك كي يخرج
بتصريحات دون ان يكون هناك رصيد لهذه
التصريحات
عمليا طبعا هناك بالنسبه للامريكيين
يريدون ان يعني يكون الامر سريا لربما هم
لا يريدون في الداخل الامريكي ان يقولوا
انهم يجرون مفاوضات مع الاير او انهم
يفرجون على الاموال الايرانيه ولكن طبعا
بالنسبه للايرانيين عندما يكون هناك
امتياز لماذا لا يكسبون هذا الامتياز وعلى
كل حال هذا الموضوع سوف يتم تسريبة في
المستقبل
قريبا
عمليا اذا ما تم تنفيذه لماذا لا يقوم
الوزير الايراني بالاعلان عنه صراحه
وينتظر تسريبه من عبر وسائل اعلام اخرى
ولهذا وانا اتصور ان السيد امير عبد الله
هيان يعني عمليا بعد ان تاكد من حصول هذا
الاتفاق اعلن عنه قبل ذلك لا يقوم لكن
الان يمكن ان نقول انه تعطل صحيح يعني
الان يمكن ان نقول انه تعطل ولو مؤقتا لكن
الان بعد النفي الامريكي بات كانه غير
موجود ولو مرحليا
على كل حال الرساله التي تلقاها السيد
امير عبد الله هيان فيها عده نصوص عده
مواضيع
واحد المواضيع موضوع الافراج عن السجناء
يعني ليس الموضوع الاساسي فقط الافراج عن
السجناء هذا الموضوع تم يعني عمليا
استقبال السيد جروسي في طهران والبحث في
حل
الخلاف النووي موضوع حل الخلافات في
المنطقه كلها تتمحور في اطار هذا الموضوع
السجناء كان احد المواضيع ولربما اتصور ان
السيد امير عبد الله هي كان يريد ان يقول
الموضوع ايضا تم وانتهى امره سيد باتانكا
لم تنجح ايران هنا في رمي الكره في الملعب
الامريكي وتحميل واشنطن مسؤوليه عدن
عدم تبادل السجناء
مره اخرى اقول واكرر مع سبق ان قلت لو ان
الجانب الايراني قلق بانه الولايات
المتحده تحاول ابقاء هذه المفاوضات السريه
فكل ما عليها ان تقوم به ان تقول غدا
تعالوا لنجلس سويه ونجم مفاوضات مباشره
واعتقد ان مبعوث الرئيس بايدن سيكون في
الدوحه او مسقط او بغداد او اي مكان في
المنطقه هذا امر يعود لايران تقرره هم لا
يريدون حديث مع امريكا بشكل مباشر اذا
سالتم لماذا اذا كنتم مستعدون تحديث معهم
بشكل غير مباشر وقسمتم السيد مالي ربط
مالي قال له لماذا تتحدثون مباشره مع
واشنطن طهران ترفض اذن اليوم يقع على
الجانب الايراني ليس الامريكي ولابد ان
نقول ان ايران
عليها ان تدخر قرار رئيسي كبير حول ما
الذي تقوم به ازاء سياستها تجاه الولايات
المتحده هل تريد اتفاق نووي جديد او تبادل
اسرى السجناء اذا اذا
بحوار واسع بعد الولايات املنا تريد فقط
اتفاق جديد بسيط كما حصلت فينا خمسه عشر
لا اعتقد ان النظام الايراني من المشرع
الى الحرس الثوري والى كل مجلس الامن
لديهم لا تقوم قرروا اتخذوا لهذا نجد ان
الايرانيين
مترددون في اي محادثات مباشره مع الولايات
عندما تقول سيد باتانكا عفوا عندما تاتي
على ذكرى السياسه الايرانيه تجاه الولايات
المتحده بشكل عام انت تتحدث هنا عما عن
الماخذ ايضا الامريكيه تجاه ايران هل لهذا
التعثر في في الاتفاقات
يعني السيد يتحدث عن اتفاق شامل حصل العمل
الماضي لكنه حتى الان لم ينفذ هل للظروف
الدوليه هل للتقارب الايراني الروسي
التقارب الايراني الصيني هل له علاقه
بتعثر هذه الاتفاقات مع الولايات المتحده
في الولايات المتحده اذا لم يكن هناك اي
احتمال لحصول اتفاق كبير جديد مع علي
طهران فان اداره بايدن حاليا تقع تحت ضغوط
كبيره جدا بان لا تقوم باي التفاوض مع
ايران فقط حول الموضوع النووي في وقت نرى
ان هناك
انتهاكات كبيره جدا لحقوق الانسان في
ايران بسبب التظاهرات التي تحصل في ايران
منذ سته وسبعه اشهر اذا فان تعرض الى ضغط
شديد من الكونغرس ومن وسائل الاعلام ومن
الشوتات الايراني لا يستطيعون توصل لاتفاق
مع السلطات الايرانيه الا اذا كانت ايران
مستعده فعلا وبشكل جاد ان تغير
سياستها ومسارها
لذلك هم
اتفاقا جديدا حول اتفاق الموضوع النووي
ولكن هذا غير مقبول ولابد لا نقبله
ايران هل هي مستعده في تغيير سياساتها
بالنهايه هذه الاتفاقات لابد ان يعني ان
تكون مترافقه مع مطالب
ومطالب الولايات المتحده في اطار السياسه
الامريكيه مطالب في اطار السياسات
الايرانيه هي مطالب واضحه هل ايران مستعده
لتليين مواقفها من اجل الوصول الى تفاهمات
اوسع في مع الولايات المتحده باختصار
يعني الموضوع ان الولايات المتحده هي جهه
لا يمكن التعويل عليها لا على توقيع
رئيسها ولا وزير خارجيتها ولا اي دبلوماسي
من الولايات المتحده نحن جربنا الولايات
المتحده من قبل يعني الاتفاق النووي قامت
الولايات المتحده وزير خارجيتها بالنيابه
عن الحكومه الامريكيه بالتوقيع عليه كانت
هناك مفاوضات مباشره بين وزراء خارجيه
ايران والولايات المتحده
ونكست الولايات المتحده بجميع ما تم
الاتفاق عليه يعني عندما يكون الطرف
المقابل طرفا لا يمكن التعويل عليه وليس
لديه اعتبار يمكن التعويل عليه يعني ما من
سبب لكي تجلس معه وتتكلم اليوم السبب الذي
يصر عليه الايراني ان يكون هناك واسطه هو
ان الامريكي دوما يكذب يعني ليس هناك
كلاما صادقا لدى الامريكي لهذا تسر تيسر
الايراني ان يكون هناك واسطه او يكون هناك
شاهد على الكلام يعني عندما يرسل الامريكي
رساله مباشره الى الايراني عبر وزير
الخارجيه العراقي ثم يكذب رساله فكيف
الحال اذا كان هناك كلام مباشر بين جانبين
وهو يقوم بتكذيب الرساله التي ارسلها شكرا
لك يعني اليوم المشكله تكمل في ان
الولايات المتحده يعني دوله لا يمكن واضح
واضح انعدام حتى الان انتهى انتهى وقتنا
واضح الثقه بين الطرفين وهذا ما يبدو
مستمرا حتى اللحظه شكرا لك دكتور عماد ابو
شناس من طهران وشكرا للدكتور اليكس
باتانكا كان معنا من واشنطن
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]